bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
l'audition de delphine batho la ministre
de l'écologie et de l'énergie a été
auditionné par les sénateurs de la
commission du développement durable et
par ceux de la commission des affaires
économiques mardi après-midi lors de
cette audition delphine batho a
notamment évoqué la question des gaz de
schiste pour elle il faut continuer à
interdire l'exploitation des gaz de
schiste en raison des dangers liés à la
fracturation hydraulique sa position
pourrait créer des désaccords au sein du
gouvernement puisque le ministre du
redressement productif
arnaud montebourg il serait quant à lui
favorable selon le journal les échos de
lundi
tout de suite donc retour à cette
audition qui a eu lieu mardi après midi
au sénat madame la ministre nous sommes
très heureux de vous accueillir ici vous
voyez d'ailleurs que nous sommes
rassemblés nombreux sénateurs pour
pardon ah oui c'est vrai que je suis
relevé et au fond de la salle comme
d'habitude ça va mieux là donc madame la
ministre de l'écologie dû développement
durable de l'énergie donc nous sommes
très heureux de vous recevoir
je dirais même que nous étions
impatients de vous recevoir et que
évidemment vous le savez le sénat
constitué une huitième commission qui
septième commission pardon qui a qui est
née de la partition de l'écho de la
grande commission économique présidée
par daniel raoul et qui a partagé cette
commission en deux groupes de 38
sénateurs qui sont ici aujourd'hui
réunies ensemble pour vous entendre et
essayez donc de vous poser un certain
nombre de questions pied sur les
problèmes les sujets les thématiques
sont sont nombreux et nombreuses
j'en citerai quelques unes mais je n'ai
pas la prétention de cadres et tout le
débat
qui j'en suis sûr va réserver une grande
partie aux échanges si vous le voulez
bien
mais bon pêle-mêle je citerai
l'organisation de la conférence
environnementale qui évidemment est un
sujet sur lequel on aimerait avoir
quelques informations
et puis ensuite bien entendu nous
n'échapperons pas au gaz de schiste nous
n'échapperons pas au code minier ou à la
filière photovoltaïque à tout ce qui est
transition écologique à la biodiversité
je ne sais pas si je peux pousser sco
snit puisque évidemment il ya ici
roland qui voyez louis
pardon qui est qui est un spécialiste
enfin bon pêle-mêle ses grands sujets
nous intéresse tous donc sans plus
tarder
je vais donner la parole à daniel raoul
est ensuite bien nous écouterons dans
une présentation de votre ministère et
puis des grandes orientations et si nous
pouvons réservé une bonne petite heure
au débat je crois que tout le monde sera
satisfait merci merci madame la ministre
nous sommes heureux de vous accueillir
ici
pour cette première des conditions ça va
être un bizutage vous allez voir comment
ça se passe nous avons quelques usages
et coutumes que nous n'allons pas
déroger est en tous les cas ce qu'on
avoue ce que nous avons déjà dit je veux
collègues ministres qui a une certaine
liberté ton sénat et que vous serez sans
doute pas déçu des questions simplement
pour vous dire qu'entre les deux
commissions il ya des cheveux
chevauchement évidemment concernant les
énergies renouvelables puisque l'énergie
relève vient de la commission des
affaires économiques mais les aspects
environnementaux aménagement du
territoire relève de la commission du
développement durable
nous sommes évidemment intéressé aussi
en tant que parlementaire de la place
que vous laisserez dans en septembre en
tous les cas la conférence
environnementale et donc la
représentation des commissions et aux
deux en dehors de l'énergie j'ai bien
relevé également que dans le périmètre
de vos délégations de vos attributions
il y avait aussi le secteur de la pêche
et de l'aquaculture
oui à face j'ai cru comprendre ça si je
me suis pas trompé
charles revêt vous n'avez pas encore la
parole ça viendra mais donc nous avons
déjà parlé avec monsieur cuvillier
ministre délégué à propos de la réforme
de la politique commune de la pêche mais
vous souhaitez peut-être en dire
quelques mots j'aimerais bien savoir où
est le périmètre exact de chacun je
pense qu'une ambiguïté sur le terme
pêche est ce qu'on pense à la pêche dans
les océans et et à la pêche
je dirais terrestre à face en jeu de
mots est donc comme le dit mon collègue
raymond vall ensuite de nous passerons
aux questions mais vous avez pour le
moment seule la parole à moins qu'ils
aient quelques perturbateurs comme
charles revêt mais ça devrait se calmer
bien messieurs les présidents
merci de votre accueil d'abord je salue
l'ensemble des sénateurs et des
sénatrices membres de vos commissions
c'est un bizutage bien bien involontaire
de ma part c'est vrai que j'ai
l'habitude du travail à l'assemblée
nationale je découvre avec plaisir la
haute assemblée donc je pense je vais
constaté certainement les habitudes mais
aussi la sagesse dans les débats
la transition écologique et énergétique
est au coeur de la politique du
gouvernement pour le redressement dans
la justice l'écologie sociale constitue
à la fois un impératif par rapport à nos
engagements en matière de lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique mais en même
temps un levier pour sortir des
difficultés économiques actuelles et
s'inscrire dans une logique vertueuse
qui est celle d'une mutation de notre
modèle de développement et nous sommes
la génération qui avons cette
responsabilité d'organiser cette cette
mutation c'est le sens du rassemblement
dans un même ministère de l'écologie de
l'environnement et en même temps de la
politique de l'énergie et pour toutes
les questions donc je l'indiqué frédéric
cuvillier à mes côtés ministre délégué
chargé des transports de la mer et de la
pêche je pense plus raisonnable une
importance égale de ses sujets que les
questions sur ces thématiques lui soit
adressé la semaine la semaine prochaine
il il travaille sur l'ensemble de ses
dossiers à mes côtés je voulais
peut-être à grands traits parce que je
pense le plus intéressant est d'avoir un
échange rappeler quelques quelques
données importantes pour la france je
viendrai dans l'instant sur les enjeux
du réchauffement de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique mais il ya un
autre enjeu dont on parle souvent - qui
est celui de la biodiversité de la perte
de biodiversité et sur laquelle je
voulais insister parce que la prise de
conscience citoyenne n'est pas accompli
aujourd'hui sur ces enjeux de
biodiversité alors que les scientifiques
considèrent que nous sommes entrés dans
la sixième grande phase d'extinction des
espèces sur le plan mondial
on évoque aujourd'hui en effet la
disparition de 12% des oiseaux de 25%
des mammifères de 32% des amphibiens
d'ici 2100 est l'une des raisons
majeures de cette situation et
l'artifice l'artificialisation continues
et croissantes des sols c'est un
phénomène qui concerne la france
puisqu'en france 600 kilomètres carrés
sont artificialisés chaque année ce qui
représente l'équivalent d'un grand
département tous les dix ans c'est
pourquoi nous avons besoin de la prise
de conscience citoyenne que j'évoquais
sur ces enjeux de la biodiversité et
c'est pourquoi le président de la
république a souhaité qu'un des
objectifs de la prochaine conférence
environnementale sur lequel je
reviendrai donc propos liminaire soit
d'engager l'élaboration d'une grande loi
cadre pour la biodiversité qui est une
qui est une ambition importante pour le
gouvernement
en ce qui concerne les enjeux du
réchauffement climatique
d'abord il ya un constat scientifique
aujourd'hui qui est avérée et que plus
personne ou presque il ya encore des
exceptions ne conteste puisque les
émissions mondiales de co2 ont augmenté
de 40 % entre 1990 et 2010 le
réchauffement climatique
aujourd'hui les prévisions le donnent
largement supérieure à deux degrés à
l'horizon 2100 2 degrés étant la
température à partir de laquelle les
incertitudes quant aux impacts croît de
façon considérable
l'union européenne vous le savez produit
13 % des émissions de co2 monde
al en baisse de 12% depuis 1990 la
france l 1 3% en légère croissance
depuis 1990 ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que la réduction de l'empreinte
carbone de notre pays est estimé à
partir de la consommation des produits
aujourd'hui n'est pas dû à nos efforts
elle est due principalement à la
désindustrialisation et à la situation
économique actuelle
je rappelle aussi que dans le paquet
énergie climat l'union européenne s'est
fixé l'objectif dit des trois fois vingt
baisse de 20% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre augmentation de 20% de
l'efficacité énergétique et de 20% des
énergies renouvelables à l'horizon 2020
en 2009 un peu plus de la moitié du
chemin était parcourue en matière
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est dans ce contexte que la france
s'est engagée à diviser ses propres
émissions par quatre à l'horizon 2050
nous sommes bien sûr déçus de l'accord a
minima qui est intervenu lors du sommet
de rio +20 nous essaierons nous essayons
de travailler toutefois à la réalisation
concrète de ce qui a été inscrit dans la
déclaration finale sur les objectifs de
développement durable
d'ores et déjà la france prépare deux
grands rendez vous internationaux jeu
c'est en particulier que laurence
rossignol travail sur le suivi des
négociations internationales sur le
climat et l'environnement
il ya deux rendez-vous au prochain
semestre le premier la conférence sur la
biodiversité qui se tiendra à hyderabad
en inde du 8 au 19 octobre prochain où
nous présideront la france présidera la
table ronde consacrée aux océans et il y
a évidemment la conférence sur le climat
de doha qui se déroulera du 26 novembre
au 7 décembre j'étais d'ailleurs hier à
berlin dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle
le dialogue de petersberg qui avait été
mis en place
après l'échec du sommet de copenhague
pour favoriser un rapprochement des
points de vue entre les principes les
principales parties intervenant dans les
négociations internationales
ce qui m'a frappé j'ai touché de près je
danse dans ces discussions la difficulté
d'avancé sur les deux points qui sont
essentiels la première qui est d'avoir
un accord contraignant engageant tous
les pays comme le prévoit la plateforme
de durban et la deuxième difficulté
c'est de trouver une vision commune
entre les pays développés les pays
émergents
et l'ensemble des parties prenantes de
la négociation sur la définition de ce
qu'est la responsabilité commune mais
différenciée c'est à dire d'une
répartition équitable et juste des
efforts de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre entre
responsabilités historiques mais aussi
évolution des réalités sur la sur la
planète entre 1990 et aujourd'hui où les
principaux pays émetteurs de gaz à effet
de serre ne sont plus tout à fait les
mêmes
et donc c'est c'est ce qui fait ce sont
les deux points d'achoppement il me
semble des négociations internationales
dans un contexte politique où les enjeux
internes un certain nombre de grandes
puissances ne rend pas facile
l'évolution des discussions malgré ça la
france a rappelé l'urgence d'agir et la
nécessité de parvenir à un accord
évidemment la transition et énergétiques
elle que souhaite engager le président
de la république elle est déterminée par
ses enjeux de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et la volonté
d'atteindre les les engagements
internationaux que nous avons pris
notamment vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne mais cette transition
énergétique s'inscrit également au
regard d'autres enjeux le premier a
trait aux emplois puisque je le rappelle
le secteur de l'énergie représente
environ 500 mille emplois directs et
indirects en france 25% des
investissements de l'industrie et plus
de 2% du pib
évidemment la compétitivité des prix de
l'énergie est un lieu vielles
d'attractivité de notre économie
absolument déterminant
un deuxième enjeu est celui de
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
l'énergie s'inscrit évidemment dans un
contexte géopolitique mondiale ou la
sécurité d'approvisionnement doit se
concevoir en termes économiques et de
diversification nécessaire des sources
d'approvisionnement je rappelle que le
poids de l'énergie dans le déficit de
notre balance commerciale puisque ses 61
4 milliards d'euros soit l'équivalent de
3% du pib en 2011
enfin la part des énergies renouvelables
restent très insuffisamment développée
dans le mix énergétique
lequel a peu évolué dans une période
récente en particulier les filières
d'énergies renouvelables ont été
fragilisés par des changements réguliers
de réglementation ou de politique
tarifaire c'est particulièrement vrai
pour le photovoltaïque et l'éolien
en ce qui concerne les perspectives que
je voulais vous présenter
bien sûr on y reviendra dans la
discussion elles sont cadrés parce qu'on
était les engagements du président de la
république dans la campagne électorale
d'abord la volonté de développer
massivement les énergies renouvelables
sans exclusive d'une part grâce à un
cadre réglementaire clair et stable et
d'autre part par un fonds de capital
investissement dédié aux énergies
renouvelables qui seraient hébergés
auprès de la future banque publique
d'investissement il s'agit avant tout de
respecter l'engagement que nous avons
pris 2 23% d'énergies renouvelables
d'ici 2020 un deuxième engagement
et vous le savez de réduire de 75 à 50%
la part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité à l'horizon 2025 et donc
la fermeture de la centrale de
fessenheim qui est la plus ancienne
durant ce quinquennat et le fait de
mener à terme le chantier de le père de
flamanville le troisième engagement
concerne la protection du pouvoir
d'achat des français puisque d'ores et
déjà 8 millions de français connaissent
une situation de précarité énergétique
c'est-à-dire qu'ils consacrent plus de
10% de leurs revenus à leur facture
d'énergie
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a pris la
décision dans le cadre du projet
d'arrêté transmis à la commission de
régulation de l'énergie de limiter à 2 %
la hausse des tarifs réglementés du gaz
et
l'électricité sans doute nous
reviendrons sur les contentieux dans les
changes avec le conseil d'état
vous savez françois hollande dans la
dent avait également repris l'idée d'une
réforme structurelle de grande ampleur
sur la progressivité des tarifs de
l'énergie et le gouvernement a indiqué
qu'il était favorable à ce qu'une
initiative parlementaire permettent de
mener à bien cette réforme dès cet
automne une réforme qui permettrait
d'allier à la fois nos objectifs en
matière sociale de lutte contre la
précarité énergétique et nos objectifs
écologiques avec un système de
tarification progressive qui permettrait
d'encourager la sobriété énergétique qui
est qui doit-être j'évoquais le
développement des énergies renouvelables
mais la sobriété l'efficacité
énergétique doit aussi être un délit
considéré comme le principal d'ailleurs
levier d'action que nous devons
mobiliser en ce qui concerne la
préparation de la conférence en vo
environnementale je voulais vous dire
d'abord qu'elle s'inscrit dans une forme
de continuité par rapport à ce qui a été
avancé majeur du grenelle de
l'environnement il faut le reconnaître
cette notion d'un partenariat écologique
a été à l'époque une avancée importante
même si la traduction concrète et
notamment la loi grenelle 2 a pu
décevoir elle n'a pas fait l'objet de la
même unanimité que la loi grenelle 1
et même si c'est aussi ça qu'il faut
souligner on constate un certain nombre
de reculs aujourd'hui on constate un
recul dans l'engagement financier de la
france en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique cet engagement
a diminué de 18% en trois ans on a
constaté des reculs aussi qu'ils ont été
signalés par le conseil économique et
social dans son avis du 15 février
dernier notamment en ce qui concerne le
développement des énergies renouvelables
les pesticides puisque la consommation
de pesticides a augmenté malgré les
engagements du grenelle de
l'environnement et puis un certain
nombre de difficultés aussi par exemple
dans la mise en oeuvre de ce qu'étaient
les engagements du grenelle en matière
de responsabilité sociale et
environnementale des entreprises puisque
les décrets qui ont été prises
vous le savez un certain nombre de
concours de controverse la conférence
environnementale s'inscrit à la fois
dans une continuité une différence c'est
qu'elle sera le point de départ d'un
processus de concertation en tout point
comparable à ce qu'a été la conférence
sociale
elle sera introduite par le président de
la république elle sera conclue par le
premier ministre elle se tiendra aux
alentours de la mi septembre en
réunissant les cinq collèges qui étaient
parties prenantes du grenelle de
l'environnement auxquels s'ajoutent et
s'ajouteront effectivement je vous le
confirme
les parlementaires puisque c'était un
point de consensus dans le bilan du
grenelle qu'il fallait associer les
parlementaires même si nous devons bien
avoir à l'esprit par rapport à la tante
nossa notamment d'un certain nombre de
deux deux corps intermédiaires engagés
dans ces concertations que une meilleure
participation des parlementaires dès
l'origine du processus
ne change rien au fait que le parlement
est souverain dans ses décisions et bien
sûr il est souverain en matière
législative au moment de débattre et de
voter la loi
c'est quelque chose qui doit parfois
être être rappelé en ce qui concerne les
sujets qui serait portée à l'ordre du
jour de cette conférence il y a les deux
priorités que j'ai évoqué la
biodiversité la transition énergétique
auquel s'ajouterait trois autres sujets
la fiscalité écologique puisque vous
savez que la france un grand retard dans
ce domaine on connaît les controverses
qu'il y avait eu notamment sur la taxe
carbone et donc il s'agit d'engager une
réflexion de fond sur la fiscalité
écologique favorisant la concertation la
plus large
deuxième sujet le lien entre santé et
environnement ou voit la récurrence
d'un certain nombre de problématiques de
santé publique liés notamment à des
pollutions à l'usagé d'un certain nombre
de produits chimiques et nous pensons
que le moment est venu d'avoir une
approche d'ensemble de ces questions et
le troisième sujet la question de la
gouvernance écologique ou la démocratie
écologique que ce soit à l'échelle
nationale ou à l'échelle locale
il se passe des choses considérable sur
les territoires que ce soit en matière
de biodiversité aujourd'hui ou de
développement des énergies renouvelables
pour prendre ses deux seuls exemples les
collectivités territoriales joue un rôle
moteur et que nous souhaitons aussi
encourager et favoriser d'ailleurs dans
toutes les dimensions qui seront celles
de la de la conférence environnementale
donc voilà les thématiques qui serait
abordé en ce qui concerne la transition
énergétique
vous savez que le président de la
république s'est engagé pour
l'organisation d'un grand débat national
et citoyens à cheval sur 2012 et 2013
qui déboucherait ensuite sur
l'élaboration d'une loi de programmation
sur la transition énergétique fixant nos
engagements et choisissant aussi nos
stratégies à la fois en matière de
sobriété énergétique que de stratégies
de développement des énergies
renouvelables tout cela doit faire
l'objet d'un débat citoyen et donc sur
cette question là
l'objet de la conférence
environnementale sera en quelque sorte
d'être la conférence de méthodes
arrêtant les modalités précises
d'organisation du débat sur la
transition énergétique dont nous
souhaitons qu'il soit un débat vivant
qu'il soit 1 débats décentralisés sur
les territoires qui permettra dans la
concertation d'établir un certain nombre
de recommandations qui serviront de
guide aux gouvernements pour l'écriture
du projet de loi de programmation sur la
sur la transition énergétique
voilà je n'ai évidemment pas aborder
l'ensemble des sujets je répondrai avec
plaisir à vos à vos questions le dernier
mot simplement pour vous dire que le
gouvernement considère que le parlement
est donc le sénat doit être partie
prenante des réformes nous voulons
laisser toute sa place bien sûr au
contrôle
mais aussi à l'initiative parlementaire
et donc moi je suis à la disposition du
sénat pour être auditionné autant qu'il
sera nécessaire pour répondre aux
questions parfois je n'aurais pas
immédiatement la réponse technique
précise mais elle sera apportée dans les
meilleurs délais et nous sommes aussi
tout à fait ouvert à ce que je le
souhaite que mes services répondent à
toutes les questions des parlementaires
dans l'est dans les meilleurs délais et
puissent contribuer à vos réflexions et
à vos travaux
merci merci ministre je vous signale que
madame la ministre devra nous quitter
impérativement à 19h30 et donc que si
vous aviez la gentillesse d'avoir des
questions concise ça arrangerait tout le
monde parce que sinon il y aura
forcément des frustrés dans les demandes
de parole est donc ce jeu commence par
claude bérit-debat merci messieurs pris
dans j'aurai beaucoup de questions à
poser mais je vais essayer d'être très
concis et ramener ma question à mon
département
comme beaucoup de collègues nous sommes
confrontés à la problématique des gaz de
schiste sur le département de la
dordogne
nous sommes confrontés à trois permis
d'explorer le permis de cahors l'autre
le permis de brive l'autre le permis de
l'eau monde de lomagne ce qui fait que
tout le tout la moitié sud est de notre
département ont tout du moins tous les
élus
élus maires conseillers généraux mêmes
parlementaires puisque je pense que mon
collègue germinal peiro qui est député
du de ce secteur
vous interpeller alors je voudrais
savoir quelle est la position du
gouvernement à quelle est votre position
par rapport par rapport au gaz de
schiste au permis d'exploiter et
d'explorer d'abord d'exploiter ensuite
est sonné la réforme du code minier qui
a été annoncé à diverses reprises
donc voilà la seule question que je vous
pose madame le ministre
merci pour équilibrer les choses
monsieur poniatowski merci monsieur le
président moi je vais me condamner à des
questions concernant l'énergie en tant
que président du groupe nrj madame la
ministre
première question sur le fasse et le
fasse et le fossé le fonds
d'amortissement des charges
d'électrification
je vous signale que c'est dans certains
départements 80% des ressources qui
permettent aux syndicats d'électricité
d'effectuer les travaux de renforcement
électrique le facé nouvelle méthode est
bloquée madame la ministre et vous le
savez car nous avons ce fonds a changé
de structure c'est maintenant un compte
d'affectation spéciale est ce qu'on
d'affectation spéciale est totalement
bloquée pour les crédits 2012 le
parlement a voté une enveloppe de 270
par dont 370 millions d'euros les
recettes sont déjà rentrés dans les
caisses de l'état puisqu'elles rendent
tous les mois chaque mois erdf verse 30
millions d'euros il ya déjà 210 millions
dans les caisses de l'état zéro ont été
versés au syndicat d'électricité alors à
la ministre le programme 2010 2011
dépend encore tout à fait réglé il ya
plusieurs syndicats d'électricité qui
attendent encore le versement d'un
reliquat 2010 2012 quand est-ce que ça
va venir je vous signale que le syndicat
d'électricité dans la ministre avec des
petites pme de 10 20 30 60 salariés et
ce sont des entreprises qui vont se
trouver en situation de faillite d'ici
très bientôt
deuxième question dans le ministre le
mécanisme de capacités qui était attendu
par la loi nome est un mécanisme très
attendu on s'en est rendu compte nous
les membres de la commission d' enquête
sur les coûts d'énergie
on nous
rappelé à l'ordre en ce sens que c'est
grâce à ses mécanismes de capacité qu'on
va pouvoir financer des unités de
production lors indispensable dans les
périodes de pointe et il y en a de plus
en plus dans les périodes chaudes et
froides française ce mécanisme les
capacités attend la sortie de deux
décrets de chez vous je croix madame la
ministre qui ne sont pas loin de la
signature là aussi peut-être que vous ne
pourrez pas nous répondre tout de suite
mais vraiment je nous avons besoin de
savoir quand est-ce que ils sortiront
troisième sujet madame la ministre
non mais attendez ça va être rapide les
compteurs linky
non mais c'est important est-ce qu'ils
sont morts il sait ce qu'ils sont morts
c'est bloqué c'est kate c'est un sujet
difficile on va remplacer tous les
compteurs en france ça représente 4
milliards d'investissements cédant 30
millions de foyers
le feu vert a été donné à edf erdf ne
veut pas s'y engager parce qu'ils n'ont
pas tout à fait la garantie de pouvoir
amortir cet investissement madame la
ministre
c'est vous qui pouvez probablement
débloqués pour une raison simple on
n'arrive pas à sortir une convention
entre la fédération de tous les
syndicats de france et erdf
parce qu'il semblerait que ces compteurs
linky ne soit pas compatible avec ce que
exige la directive efficacité
énergétique car ils seraient pas assez
intelligent je crois que c'est faux si
vous pouviez apportez-vous la garantie
que ça ne l'était ça débloquerait les
compteurs linky
merci madame la ministre oui marcel
deneux une question si c'est possible
oui mesdames les ministres dans quatre
de l'office parlementaire dont je suis
vice-président nous avons conduit des
travaux sur l'avenir du nucléaire et la
transition énergétique ces travaux ont
été publiés après que nous avions fait
savait que christian bataille et bruno
sido au début de janvier
or ces temps ci une organisation non
gouvernementale qui n'est quand même pas
loin du gouvernement a publié des
travaux d'un expert qui fait autorité
qui constatant la crise financière et la
rareté des capitaux faire pareil
des différences notables entre gretz six
filières qui concourent à la production
d'électricité
est ce que cette notion d'utilisation
optimum du capital disponible est de
nature à influencer fortement les
orientations gouvernementales en matière
d'énergies renouvelables
ce deuxième 30 secondes président en
mars 2003 madame j'ai acheté ma première
voiture hybride
depuis ce temps l'or j'ai vu 286 milles
kilomètres de fait en voiture hybride je
vous laisse calculer les tonnages c'est
pas moins de 30 tonnes de co2 et puis à
l'époque avec la naïveté politique qui
caractérise souvent des militants
authentiques
j'avais cru avec bernard darniche
convainquent le ministre de l'équipement
que lille était bien de rouler en
voiture hybride
ce qui fut fait ce ministre de
l'équipement acheté une voiture pour sow
sa communauté d'agglomération dont il
était président et pour le ministère
nous avons buté sur le directeur de
cabinet les choses ont changé maintenant
est ce que vous pouvez me dire
est ce que vous pouvez me dire que votre
ministère va être exemplaire en matière
d'achats de voitures propres
monsieur l'abbé oui madame la ministre
je souhaiterais connaître votre position
sur votre position sur le soutien public
apporté à l'industrie des agrocarburants
lequel pose un certain mental comme qui
suit c'est très bien oui mais avec avec
alors avec un avec un tout petit
développement quand même puisque pour
annuellement c'est à hauteur de 196
millions d'euros d'exonération fiscale
le soutien de l'état cette filière cette
filière qui a qui a montré ses limites
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
environnemental et énergétique quand on
en fait le bilan et qui d'autre part on
est on est obligé pour assurer les 10%
d'importer ce qui est de ce fait on
contribue à l'accaparement des terres et
tous les effets les effets collatéraux
générés sur les cultures vivrières des
pays tiers
autant de choses qui font remettre en
question selon nous la question des
algues des agrocarburants et on
souhaitait avoir votre position s'il
vous plaît
et testons
et de fisher et ensuite je pense madame
mais va y en avoir 15
oui mais pour la clarté des réponses
c'est un petit conseil pédagogique si on
en prenait 7 8 dans un premier une
première vague et puis ensuite
non non non c'est monsieur testons qui
la parole et monsieur le président
madame la ministre
deux questions que je présente en deux
phrases la première donc concerne la
révision du code minier que vous avez
annoncé
allez vous reprendre lors de cette
révision les propositions figurant dans
la proposition de loi déposée par le
groupe socialiste du sénat
c'était donc à la fin du mois de juillet
2011 après que nous ayons voté contre le
texte qui avait été présenté par le
gouvernement précédent la texte de la
proposition jacob et la deuxième
question porte sur la situation
préoccupante de la sous traitance dans
le nucléaire et plus particulièrement
des salariés quelle est la position du
gouvernement à ce sujet puisqu'on sait
qu edf a tendance à externaliser de plus
en plus de prestations de chantier des
entreprises extérieures
je suis fiché oui madame la ministre je
m'appelle jean luc fichet j'habite le
département du finistère et qui est bien
connu malheureusement par ces algues
vertes jeu beat la limite entre le
finistère les côtes d'armor et vous
savez que c'est aujourd'hui un problème
grave
inquiétant ce dossier ce qu'elles se
sont penchés pas mal de ministre à
chaque fois ils sont venus nous ont dit
on va vous aider et ils sont repartis et
rien ne se produit sinon que l'on reste
avec des algues vertes qui sont de plus
en plus importante qui ait posé problème
d'odeurs des problèmes visuels des
problèmes sur notre programme
touristique et qui nous coûtent
excessivement cher
donc j'aimerais simplement savoir si
vous avez une approche de ce dossier des
algues vertes
et si vous avez à l'esprit quelques
décisions qui pourraient nous rassurer
dans un terme assez court parce que cela
devient urgent et puis dans un terme
plus long parce que l'on sait que ces
algues vertes proviennent de pollution
qui sont pour l'essentiel d'origine
agricole
le monde agricole a mis en place des
dispositifs
ils sont sans doute insuffisant et
nécessite donc des accompagnements pour
que demain on n'est plus ce problème qui
est comme je vous le dis grave et c'est
aussi un problème de santé puisque
récemment nous avait un mort de la mort
d'un cheval et la mort de sangliers
je vous remercie merci monsieur yves
rome bien madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre
dreux interrogé suite à la panne
logiciel qu'a connu orange sur les
difficultés et la dépendance à laquelle
se trouvent confrontés la plupart de nos
concitoyens en zone urbaine comme en
zone rurale la téléphonie mobile est un
outil incontournable de notre quotidien
et vous le savez la demande est
croissante war exponentielle la
difficulté d'éligibilité de l'ensemble
des zones
se heurte à des phénomènes
contradictoires qui se traduisent par
les études conduites dans le cadre du
grenelle de la téléphonie grenelle des
ondes pour pas dire qu'elle est quelle
est votre position à la matière car bon
nombre de zones rurales notamment vivent
comme une discrimination la non
éligibilité aux outils nomades de la
communication aujourd'hui c'est l'objet
de ma première question
la deuxième question partagera avec vous
le souci km il président de la
république de travailler en termes de
compétitivité sur la facture énergétique
j'ajouterai à votre propos une autre
facture que vous n'avez pas évoqué mais
qui est à mes yeux tout à fait
conséquente
c'est la facture liée au traitement des
ordures ménagères avec l'appétence de
certains territoires a généré des
équipements type incinérateurs qui ont
des coûts exponentiels et qui vont
exposer les populations notamment dans
mon propre département de l'oise nous
n'avons pas réussi malgré une adoption
de pdm à qui a été contrariée par
certaines volontés locales à interdire
la création de deuxième les sénateurs
qui au delà de l'impact écologique
créerait des troubles profonds dans la
facture qui devrait être acquittée par
les consommateurs j'aimerais sur ces
deux sujets connaître votre position est
la miss
oui madame la ministre je serai deux
questions l'une sur l'énergie et la
biomasse et l'autre sur l'eau j'aurais
voulu connaître la position du
gouvernement sur l'utilisation de la
biomasse comme source d'énergie
susceptible de produire de l'électricité
et quelle était la position par rapport
aux as au grand appel à projets de type
creux qui permettent à quai ou qui sont
très consommateurs de biomasse et
assèche la ressource au niveau local au
détriment des petites unités de
production qui ont été mises en place ma
deuxième question porte sur l'eau et sur
la possibilité d'intervention des
agences de l'eau dans la partie amont
qui est soumise à beaucoup de
restrictions notamment pour les
protections de zones de captage pour
l'amélioration de la qualité de l'eau et
de voir s'il était possible d'avoir une
plus grande participation des agences de
l'eau dans les installations nécessaires
à l'aménagement des réseaux à
l'amélioration des réseaux et du
traitement des déchets dans les zones de
montagne notamment où les zones rurales
qui sont soumises à des exigences très
profonde et qui ne n'ont aucune retombée
de la taxe pollution ou de façon très
infime type art protection spéciale
michel bécot ne l'avait oublié dans nos
deux listes moi je veux oui messieurs
merci une région inconnue mais merci
président d'abord je voulais féliciter
la ministre puisque finalement pour la
confiance qui lui a été fait c'est une
de ses vrilles n merci de son
intervention à la
j'ai faut bien un petit peu de
chauvinisme je lisais dans la presse ce
matin madame la ministre que le ministre
de la réindustrialisation ne ferme plus
la porte au gaz de schiste
alors je voudrais avoir votre avis sur
cela et en deux les forages en guyane
rend obligatoire la consultation du
public avant l'attribution de permis de
recherche c'est une chance je pense
pour la france c'est une chance pour
notre pays
si les gisements si l'importance des
gisements est confirmée et je voudrais
aussi vous demander dans ce cas-là de
novaes vous votre accord pour attribuer
les permis de recherche
la parole est à madame la ministre pour
une première série de réponses et on
entamera derrière il ya encore une
dizaine de demandes de prise de parole
je vous rappelle la contrainte
ah bah je sais pas il va falloir
s'arrêter un moment madame la ministre
vous avez la parole alors j'ai eu plein
de papiers sur d'abord pour la la
question de claude bérit débat sur les
gaz de schiste le gouvernement maintient
clairement et nettement sa position
l'interdiction de l'exploitation des gaz
de schiste est indiscutable en l'état
des techniques
je rappelle que les risques sont avérées
est considérable la fracturation
hydraulique génère de façon durable des
pollutions et nulle part je dis bien
nulle part il a été démontré que
l'exploitation des gaz de schiste
pouvait être fait sans conséquence pour
la santé et l'environnement et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'avait rappelé le
président de la république dans sa
campagne électorale
permettez moi d'ailleurs de souligner
que le précédent gouvernement avait lui
accorder plusieurs permis concernant les
gaz de schiste avant que les réactions
des associations des citoyens mais aussi
des élus des territoires concernés que
vous avez rappelé n'oblige
à prendre une loi spécifique et a
accordé des permis
pardon à abroger des permis qui avait
été accordé j'ajoute aussi que le
précédent gouvernement n'a pas procédé à
la réforme du code minier réforme qui
est indispensable et qui avait été
exigée par le conseil d'état en décembre
2010 au moment de la codification du
code minier codification qui s'est fait
à droit constant alors que ce texte dans
son état actuel n'est pas conforme à
l'article 7 de la charte de
l'environnement cette charte prévoit
l'obligation d'information et de
participation du public préalablement à
toutes les décisions ayant un impact sur
l'environnement
il s'agit d'une obligation
constitutionnelle que le code minier ne
respecte pas ce qui veut dire que il y a
une fragilité juridique de l'ensemble
des permis délivrés à l'heure actuelle y
compris sur les hydrocarbures
conventionnels
cette réforme du code minier
le premier ministre l'a confirmé dans
son discours de politique générale elle
va être mené à bien dans la concertation
et le plus rapidement possible un groupe
de travail va être mise en place un
projet de loi est en préparation pour la
fin de l'année 2012
ainsi non seulement l'exploitation des
gaz de schiste restera interdite en
france
en l'état des techniques mais en plus
notre pays sera doté d'un code minier
conforme à la constitution
je voulais répondre ensuite à la
question pardon de monsieur poniatowski
d'abord sur le fasse et puisque c'est
une réforme
dont nous avons hérité je rappelle que
le fonds d'amortissement des charges
d'électrification a été transformé en
compte d'affectation spéciale fin 2011
mais effectivement cette réforme a été
mal préparée il y avait eu d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d' alerte qui avait
demandé un petit délai supplémentaire il
ya eu des difficultés puisque le
ministère a dû faire face à des
problèmes administratifs et et comptable
pour payer les aides qui retarde les
dépenses et donc les projets des
collectivités je sais que c'est un
problème sérieux nous travaillons
actuellement sur les procédures pour
avoir plus de souplesse tout en
respectant les règles d'engagement des
dépenses publiques et mon but est que la
situation soit normalisée le plus
rapidement possible en ce qui concerne
le mécanisme de capacité effectivement
le défi comme vous l'avez dit c'est de
traiter les pointes électrique pour cela
une nouvelle régulation est nécessaire
j'ai changé d'ailleurs hier avec mes
collègues ministres de l'énergie
allemands et
royaume uni qui ont le même type de
problématique et souhaite une réflexion
européenne en la matière nécessaire pour
développer les effacements mais aussi
pour assurer les investissements de
production et donc j'ai examinée à
l'heure actuelle le décret et la réforme
qui permettrait d'aller dans le bon sens
enfin sur linky bien entendu nous sommes
en train d'examiner cela
de façon générale nous souhaitons
développer tous les outils qui
permettent d'améliorer la sobriété
énergétique que les consommateurs est
une visibilité les usagers de
l'électricité et une visibilité de leur
consommation vous avez évoqué les
problèmes de structure du financement et
de l'amortissement des investissements
il y a aussi une interrogation pour
s'assurer que linky disposera de toutes
les technologies permettant justement
d'être également dans une stratégie
d'effacement et qu'il soit bien plus que
ça c'est quelque chose qui était acté
gratuit pour les usagers ce qui pose la
question de la structure du financement
c'est un sujet sur lequel le
gouvernement travaille avec la volonté
d'aboutir mais l'investissement est en
effet financièrement très important je
n'ai pas compris je prie je préfère
l'avouer la question de marcel deneux
sur l'optimisation du capital disponible
peut être n'était ce pas suffisamment
attentive auquel cas je vous inviterai à
reposer votre question en ce qui
concerne la voiture hybride
il est évidemment nécessaire de soutenir
l'achat de voitures hybrides française
cela le président de la république l'a
indiqué d'ailleurs dans son entretien du
14 juillet nous réfléchissons à l'heure
actuelle à la pérennisation et à
l'évolution du bonus malus il faudra je
crois
envisager aussi la perspective à moyen
terme de pouvoir avoir des voitures
hybrides française essence
c'est une perspective qu'il faudra
ouvrir et discuter avec nous avec nos
constructeurs en tout état de cause je
suis en train de veiller à l'exemplarité
de mon propre ministère dans ce domaine
et donc de procéder à l'examen des
achats raisonnable puisque un euro
dépensé doit être un euro utile mais
effectivement exemplaire en ce qui
concerne les agrocarburants je voulais
indiqué à notre collègue monsieur à
votre collègue monsieur l'abbé
qu'effectivement le développement des
biocarburants est encadrée par la
directive européenne de 2009
mais vous le savez la commission
elle-même évalue l'impact à l'heure
actuelle du changement d'affectation des
sols liée au développement des
biocarburants
elle n'a pas encore rendu ses
conclusions
les impacts sur la préservation des
ressources et le bilan carbone sont
assez discuté une étude de l'ademe et de
l'inra vont dans le vendeur le va dans
le même sens
j'ai engagé sur ce sujet des échanges
avec le ministre de l'agriculture et
donc nous sommes très attentifs à la
conclusion de deux ses travaux comme à
l'évaluation de du dispositif en ce qui
concerne le code minier la question de
monsieur testons alors j'avoue
malheureusement mon ignorance du contenu
de la proposition de loi de juillet 2011
mais j'imagine qu'elle devait ressembler
à celle que j'avais moi même signé à
l'assemblée nationale bon peut-être avec
des différences en tout état de cause
sur la réforme du code minier
lorsque je vous disais qu'un groupe de
travail va être mise en place il sera
composé des cinq collèges du grenelle de
l'environnement il procédera à
l'ensemble des auditions nécessaires et
bien sûr il examinera l'ensemble des
travaux parlementaires qui s'étaient
déjà penchés sur sur ce sujet de même
que les recommandations du conseil
d'état
en ce qui concerne la sous traitance
dans le dans le noeud
dans le nucléaire c'est quelque chose
c'est une situation à laquelle je suis
très attentive non seulement pour des
raisons sociales mais aussi pour des
raisons de oui c'est monsieur testons
qui avait posé la question mais aussi
pour des questions de sûreté
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire reconnaît
elle même que le facteur humain doit
être un pilier de la sûreté nucléaire et
donc la formation des personnels la
qualité de leurs conditions de travail
doit être au coeur des réformes
apportées dans les prochaines années
le président de la république avait
évoqué cette préoccupation lors de lors
de la campagne électorale en évoquant
l'interdiction de la sous traitance pour
les travaux de sécurité les plus
importants ou le fait d'augmenter
sensiblement les exigences imposées aux
exploitants en cas de recours à des
prestataires pour des pour des
opérations courantes
effectivement c'est un sujet d'attention
constance sur lequel nous allons engager
et approfondir les discussions avec les
opérateurs en ce qui concerne le plan
contre les algues vertes
monsieur fichet vous le savez il ya un
plan algues vertes qui avait été établi
en février 2010 concernant huit baies
bretonnes dans lesquelles ce phénomène
un impact sanitaire avec des risques
d'intoxication environnementale d'
atteinte à la biodiversité économique
avec non seulement des pertes
touristique mais aussi un problème
économique pour pour l'ensemble du
territoire
les mesures qu'ils purent hâtif son sont
prises chaque été pour limiter les
risques sanitaires ça veut dire que les
algues sont ramassées dans un délai
rapide avant leur décomposition
alors ce qui concerne les mesures
préventives qui sont cruciales
puisqu'il s'agit pas simplement de
dépenser un million d'euros chaque année
pour ramasser les algues vertes sur les
plages mais de s'attaquer aux causes de
ce phénomène
il s'agit de prendre des mesures
permettant de réduire le flux nitrates
dans les eaux et des mesures préventives
donc devait être prise dans les huit
baies dès 2013 pour satisfaire aux
premières échéances du plan dans un
certain nombre de baies les discussions
ont bien avancé les concertations pour
définir ces mesures préventives adaptées
aux situations locales
ce n'est pas le cas dans tout et
notamment
dans deux bus ou les discussions la baie
de l'orne et la baie de freiner ou les
discussions n'ont pas avancé à mes yeux
suffisamment c'est pourquoi j'ai donné
instruction aux préfets de la région
bretagne dans ces deux territoires là de
prendre des arrêtés de zones soumises à
contraintes environnementales faute que
les concertations et ait pu aboutir je
rappel sur ce sujet la commission
européenne a engagé en 2011 une demande
d'information et de contentieux sont
engagés en application de la directive
nitrates
en ce qui concerne le grenelle des
antennes
vous savez qu'il y avait dix
orientations qui avait été retenu et
trois actions qui sont en cours
il y avait une expérimentation d'une
faisabilité technique en matière
d'abaissement d'exposition notamment je
crois à paris dans le 14e arrondissement
j'avais un échange tout à l'heure avec
l'association des maires de france qui
me rappelait les attentes des maires des
communes sur sur ces questions et leur
sentiment d'être un peu seul face aux
choix qu'il faut faire entre la
nécessité que la population puisse avoir
puisse capter pour téléphoner et en même
temps elle est l'acceptabilité et les
questions qui sont posées concernant les
antennes donc le but ce serait que cette
expérimentation on puisse en tirer les
conclusions assez rapidement ensuite il
y adeux prévu des nouvelles procédures
de concertation préalable à
l'installation d'antennes et la mise en
place d'un nouveau dispositif de
surveillance qui va faire l'objet d'un
décret et d'un arrêté qui sont en
préparation et sur lesquels je
consulterai aussi les associations
d'élus et l'ensemble de ceux qui étaient
partie prenante au grenelle au grenelle
des antennes
en ce qui concerne la biomasse moi c'est
une énergie renouvelable à laquelle je
crois beaucoup notamment au bois énergie
il faut avoir conscience que la moitié
des énergies renouvelables aujourd'hui
en france c'est la biomasse c'est vrai
qu'on parle beaucoup et c'est légitime
de l'éolien du photovoltaïque mais il
faut toujours avoir à l'esprit cette
donnée sachant que la filière bois me
semble être une filière stratégique
après avec effectivement le fait
d'éviter des conflits d'usagé donc
d'être dans une stratégie globale de
filières qui permettent de valoriser des
sous-produits et des sous-produits vous
vous avez raison de dire que la priorité
pour la biomasse doit être la chaleur et
que l'électricité par cogénération
d'abord elle est en 2e rang qu'il faut
éviter les conflits d'usagé et qu'il ne
faut pas gaspiller la ressource en
faisant de l'électricité sans co
génération il est vrai qu'il ya eu
quelques cas qui ne se reproduiront pas
mais je pense par contre que la
stratégie entre des grands projets
géants connaissait notamment sur
collègues dans les deux sèvres
des projets importants liés à une
utilisation industrielle de la chaleur
ont leur ont leur place c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs dans les arbitrages
budgétaires j'ai souhaité préserver le
fonds chaleur qui est un levier
important et il y a bien entendu aussi à
développer les petites unités notamment
les ça se fait beaucoup les chaudières
bois avec les réseaux de chaleur
je crois qu'il faut pas opposer l'un à
l'autre à la condition que nous
utilisions des ressources nationales je
rappelle que nos forêts progresse et
qu'on ne soit pas dans des situations il
y aurait de l'importation de bois venus
de loin ça fait référence à une
situation locale
ça c'est pas un modèle vraiment c'est
évidemment pas un modèle j'ai sans doute
omis des réponses à des sujets
sur les ordures mais la facture des
ordures ménagères alors on me dit en
même temps excusez moi je préfère
revenir vers vous sur sur ces deux
sujets là et l'incinérateur
alors j'ai pas fait je m'excuse ici que
les à la problématique que j'ai les
populations une seconde j'ai l'air des
équipements lourds ne sont pas optimisés
en matière d'accueil des ordures
ménagères qui font l'objet d'une
diminution grâce des politiques de tri
il faudrait éviter que certains grands
groupes en complicité avec certains élus
privilégient la construction
d'équipements qui seront en
sous-capacité et qui vont générer des
coûts que le citoyen devra acquitter et
qui viendra s'ajouter au coût de la
facture énergétique
je connais un certain nombre de
situations locales ça me paraît être une
remarque de bon sens
aidez nous à régler ce problème alors
monsieur navarro oui monsieur le
président madame la ministre
suite aux recommandations du grenelle de
l'environnement
le snuipp a prévu de faire un effort et
l'onm sous le transport ferroviaire au
bon nombre d'articles dans la presse ou
de rumeurs semblerait laissé
sous-entendre que ce serait remis en
cause cette logique-là dont ça c'est la
question si nous la logique de diminuer
le développement du ferroviaire dans le
slip d'accord en termes de volume
financier de la question est ce que
madame la ministre vous êtes toujours
fondée à promouvoir le transport
ferroviaire
ça c'est la question et puis deux
suggestions pour vous aider à trouver
des solutions
premièrement il se croit qu'il serait
temps d'accélérer la taxe poids lourds
il deuxième suggestion il faudrait
refonder le versement transport
avec cette taxe majoré dingue le parti
aux régions qui ont une grande
compétence ce transport et qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de l'accomplir
et juste pour compléter peut-être ce que
j'ai compris parce qu'il ya dû y avoir
deux choses dans ta question en vert
c'est le transport ferroviaire
est-ce que tu évoques la diminution des
lignes tgv prévus où est ce que je veux
favoriser le fret et les voyageurs et la
maintenance des lignes existantes
parce que il y aura tout ça oui monsieur
bien messieurs les présidents
madame la ministre chers collègues
d'abord madame la ministre pour vous
remercier d'intégrer officiellement les
parlementaires dans les discussions sur
les trayons de type grenelle première
chose
la deuxième chose monsieur le président
je souhaitais soulevé le problème des
transports et j'aimerais savoir madame
la ministre
quelle est l'articulation entre vous et
le ministre délégué dans un précédent
gouvernement dans le précédent
gouvernement il y avait une articulation
qui était légèrement différente donc mon
cul par un peu des transports j'aimerais
savoir à qui je dois m'adresser pour
concrètement pouvoir travailler et faire
en sorte que ces dossiers avancent en
l'occurrence
cette articulation aujourd'hui ne me
paraît pas suffisamment clair et vous
avez vous même dit tout à l'heure que
c'était en fait frédéric cuvillier donc
si vous pouvez me le confirmer auquel
cas je sais exactement où je vais
m'adresser à quels ministères pourquoi
parce que d'une part en tant que
rapporteur du snit
que devient le site le schéma national
des infrastructures de transport avec à
la clé les futures lgv le tunnel lyon on
tuerait le cas non seulement c c'est des
choses importantes qui touchent
éventuellement le développement durable
deuxième sujet de préoccupation c'est
les véhicules électriques et les bornes
de recharge qui s'en occupe
parce que là encore on a un sujet majeur
et j'aimerais savoir quelle est la
politique que le gouvernement entend
mener dans ce domaine là est troisième
et dernière chose vous avez programmé
une conférence environnementale qui
prévoit toute une série de points et qui
ne parle pas des transports alors que
les transports sont à la base de 26 %
des gaz à effet de serre et donc et donc
sur l'environnement et l'écologie sa une
et c'est à mon sens un impact pourquoi
et que dois je faire alors pour défendre
les transports dans ce beau pays et
l'environnement annoncé mirassou dévore
monsieur mirassou je sais pas où il est
passé et la de question madame la
ministre
une qui d'ailleurs n'a pas encore été
évoqué que chacun connaît ici les
avatars subit encore dernièrement par le
secteur photovoltaïque dû à de multiples
raisons et notamment parce que on a
confondu la demande et les capacités de
francs s'ils sont surajoutés pas faire
l'historique et baisse brutale tarifs de
rachat plus le moratoire bien signé
d'une certaine manière par la fin
programmée mais en tout cas il ne pose
assez les espérances de désaltérante de
ce secteur d'activité la question est
très simple
qu'est ce que vous entendez faire pour
promouvoir une véritable filière du
photovoltaïque à la fois sur le plan
industriel et en mettant sur le plan
réglementaire et ensuite madame la
ministre chargée mon fusil d épaule pour
vous interpeller sur quelque chose que
vous avez un char je veux parler des
chasseurs et des pratiques cynégétiques
dans ce pays va te passe à savoir que
récemment une loi a été votée qui a du
reste été votées en première intention
au sénat et qui a été voté conforme à
l'assemblée nationale et qui entendaient
à la fois marquer une pause dans une
spirale terrible au niveau d'une
inflation législative et a maintenant de
faire en sorte à marca une pause de
réconcilier ou un temps en tout cas
tenté de le faire l'ensemble de ceux qui
s'intéressent à la nature en
reconnaissant dans leur passage et les
chasseurs comme étant des arts des
agents de la biodiversité à part obtient
donc la question que je vous pose
madame la ministre à vous rappelant au
passage deux chiffres un million trois
cent mille chasseurs inscrits dans 80
milles association avec un poids
économique de 2 milliards et demi
d'euros
pas donc de l'armée c'est pour bien
clément et donc la question que je vous
pose c'est de savoir comment vous allez
vous y prendre pour établir un dialogue
constructif et partenariale entre votre
ministère et le monde la charge et si je
pose cette question c'est que
l'actualité récente m'autorise à la
pause et s'agissant d'un projet d'arrêté
que vous allez finalisée avant la fin du
mois de juillet s'ils allaient evelyne
didier s'y frayer avec les campagnes
étaient terminés c'est le service
apparaît parents l'état voix merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
nous sommes heureux de vous de faire ses
jeux
j'ai deux questions la première concerne
le code minier
il existe au niveau national une
commission des risques miniers
cette commission pour l'instant à cesser
ces travaux elle était présidée par jean
pierre kucheida qui naquit ne s'est pas
représenté comme on le sait donc c'est
commission devrait il faudrait d'abord
que les les députés désigne les membres
de cette commission et qu'ensuite elle
reprenne ses travaux au titre du sénat
j'en faisais partie
je crois que j'en fais toujours partie
d'ailleurs et donc je souhaiterais que
cette commission souhaite associer aux
travaux du code minier
là ma deuxième et donc je voudrais
savoir ce que vous en pensez
mon deuxième sujet ce sont les déchets
les déchets ménagers sont c'est un sujet
qui concerne absolument tous les élus
qui sont autour de ces tables et tous
les élus d'une manière générale le
groupe déchets du sénat que j'ai
l'honneur de présider a décidé de
reprendre ses travaux et s'est auto
saisie d'un certain nombre de sujets
comme l'adéquation entre le projet et le
territoire avec en sous jacent le
développement local le maintien des
filières industrielles et
l'éco-conception et le bilan des
filières de rennes ensuite nous
souhaiterions faire un état des lieux
des filières de valorisation et
notamment la valorisation des matières
on parle beaucoup de la valorisation
énergétique et on a vu tout à l'heure
que les incinérateurs sont loin d'être
les bienvenus mais il faudrait davantage
parler de la valorisation matière et
donc nous nous souhaiterions approfondir
également nous souhaiterions travailler
sur le rôle de conseils de l'ademe et
nous en avons déjà parlé
swallows qui est venu et qui a été
auditionnée par notre commission
la question bien sûr des tarification
des redevances de la facturation et du
coup globalement pour les usagers nous
savons qu'aujourd'hui dans cette période
de crise alors même que le loyer
augmente que l'énergie augmentent que
l'eau aussi est un sujet pour certaines
familles et bien la question du coût des
déchets qui augmente en permanence va
devenir nous en sommes convaincus une
vraie question est donc nous
souhaiterions revoir ce sujet et enfin
nous voulions également nous nous
pencher sur la pénibilité des travaux d
du travail et des métiers du tri
notamment avec là aussi en parallèle la
question des filières d'insertion qui
parfois alors qu'elles ont travaillé mis
en place toute la filière se voit
souffler les les marchés une fois que la
filière est organisée par les groupes
qui du coup s'intéresse à la question
donc voila voila tous les sujets que
nous aimerions dont nous aimerions
parler dans ce groupe
nous nous aimerions vous rencontrez plus
précisément sur ce sujet ou en tout cas
vos services de telle sorte que nous
voyons comment nous pourrions être
associé dans les propositions ou les
projets de loi dans la mesure où
malheureusement on a toujours tendance
sur ce sujet à voir fleurir des
amendements pour la loi au moment de la
loi de finances au moment de la loi de
finances rectificative à l'occasion d'un
texte ou d'un autre on a des cavaliers
comme ça des décrets qui sortent sans
qu'il y ait véritablement association
des parlementaires et nous souhaiterions
vraiment que vous que vous nous
permettiez de travailler en amont avec
vous sur ces sujets merci de votre
réponse
eu cure comment dantec mettrait corps
monsieur dantec jeu je me doutais que
j'aurai une remarque monsieur président
donc je vais effectivement être court
vous avez dit madame la ministre que
vous étiez à notre disposition mais nous
sommes aussi à votre disposition et
j'aurai le plaisir par exemple dans les
prochains jours de vous adresser le
compte rendu du débat sur la
biodiversité
le groupe écologiste a organisé dans
l'hémicycle pour la première fois
c'était en février je vois que
effectivement et je m'en réjouis la
biodiversité devient un enjeu majeur de
politique publique nous en parlons
vraiment et puis demain et le président
peut dire de ce qui est là nous rendrons
publiques la commission d' enquête sur
le prix de l'électricité là aussi à
l'initiative du groupe écologiste et
j'ai écouté avec attention vos réponses
notamment sur la question du mécanisme
de capacités je vous rejoins totalement
dans la pertinence technique de votre
réponse sur le fait que c'est à
l'échelle européenne aujourd'hui qu'il
faut envisager les mécaniques de
capacité que l' approche franco
française sur l'électricité ne
correspond plus à l'interconnexion et
que c'est bien dans ce cadre aujourd'hui
qu'il faut avoir les réponses et vous
trouverez dans ce rapport je pense des
éléments probants sur le quotient
intellectuel du fameux compteurs linky
qui permettront d'avancer dans le débat
je crois que vous avez parlé en
introduction de la question du
réchauffement climatique est
effectivement une question centrale et
je voulais vous entendre sur la manière
dont la france va continuer à porter la
position européenne on voit bien dans
les négociations internationales que je
suis plus de plusieurs années que c'est
l'europe qui porte fondamentalement
l'ambition à l'échelle mondiale et qui a
aujourd'hui sur la table deux points
précis sur lequel je vous questionne qui
sont d'abord est ce que l'europe va
tenir la position concernant la taxation
sur les carburants du transport aérien à
l'échelle européenne c'est pas un accord
mondial mais bien une position
européenne et plus globalement y compris
parce que ce sont des recettes
extrêmement importante potentiellement
pour le budget de la france dans les
prochaines années
est ce que la france va porter auprès de
ses partenaires européens une stratégie
pour remonter le prix de la tonne co2
dans le cadre des permis d'émissions qui
sont un point extrêmement important
c'est 5
milliards de recettes pour le budget des
états européens potentiellement à
échéance de quelques années donc des
enjeux majeurs au niveau climatique
européen
merci monsieur poite pro oui oui merci
madame la ministre ma question s'adresse
à la fois vous met aussi à votre
collègue cuvillier miniser transport
mais ça a été plus ou moins fleuret tout
à l'heure au sujet des déclarations de
vos collègues
cahuzac et montebourg concernant la
l'abandon ou l'élagage des des projets
lgv et pour monsieur montebourg qui a
parlé de mise à plat des projets lgv et
comme vous avez parlé tout à l'heure à
la fois de la lutte contre le changement
climatique la limitation des gaz à effet
serre on sait que le transport en commun
sncf et surtout lgv peuvent permettre de
limiter les gaz à effet serre moi je
voulais savoir simplement quelle était
votre position à titre personnel sur
voilà le développement ou non des lignes
lgv
sachant que les déclarations qui ont été
faites par les uns des autres
bien sûr inquiéter les élus toutes
sensibilités confondues sur un certain
nombre de projets alors on peut toujours
évoquer le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
financement pour des projets qui sont à
dix ou quinze ans c'est toujours facile
de dire que les prédécesseurs n'ont pas
prévu les les financements mais quand on
fait des perspectives d'avenir on sait
bien qu'on n'a pas forcément les sous
dans sa poche et qu'on il faut les
prévoir à moyen terme
donc merci de de nous dire quel est
votre point de vue sur le sujet parce
que ça me paraît important pour l'avenir
de territoires isolés justement de la
grande vitesse même rossignol mais
madame la ministre
merci toutes ces réponses moi je vais
vous et quelques questions plus de
méthode et de feuille de route c'est
préparer le moyen terme et long terme
sans perdre une minute si j'ai bien
compris donc conférence conférence
environnementales les mois de septembre
et lancement d'un grand débat sur
tensions énergétiques
la question porte sur l'articulation
entre le débat transition énergétique
sont facilement son débat transition
énergétique et des mesures qui vous
seriez amené à prendre avant la fin de
ce calendrier débat transition
énergétique projet de loi et l'adoption
d'une loi premier semestre 2013
en même temps on constate que ce soit
sur la question de la tarification ou
sur l'éolien ou sur les préoccupations
évocateur par mon collègue mirassou sur
le photovoltaïque qu'une série de
contraintes pèsent lourdement sur ce
secteur est ce que on va pour toutes les
mesures attendre la fin du débat
transition énergétique et le projet de
loi ou est ce que vous envisagez d'en
prendre un certain nombre avant qui
serait une mesure de nature
réglementaire pour lever et accélérer le
développement de ses secteurs
ma deuxième question pour vous inviter à
garder quelques décrets qui ont été
publics prix et publié par le patient
gouvernement dans la dernière période 1
sur l'affichage publicitaire qui est
totalement contraire à l'esprit de la
loi grenelle aux qualités supposées se
s'appliquer et un autre sur la
recentralisation de l'ademe et la mise
sous tutelle quasiment d'états d'âme par
les préfets qui a été pris d'ailleurs
pendant qu'elle palmistes de
l'environnement que me environnement
était partie faire porte parole du camp
d'un candidat et le ministre de
l'intérieur en a profité pour reprendre
recentraliser l'ademe et la repasser sur
l'autorité des préfets
est ce qu'un créé de vives émotions donc
pour vous inviter à regarder aussi ce
sujet là enfin vous avez eu l'amabilité
de d'évoquer le groupe de travail sur
les négociations climatiques
environnementales internationales que
nous animons je présidais quelques
collègues
ce groupe de travail a vocation à
renforcer les liens entre les citoyens
et les négociations est un achat qui
sont bien loin d'eux et de ce point de
vue là le débat au parlement nous ont
parlé de quelque chose de très important
donc pour à l'occasion de jours bagne
nous avions eu un débat
sur les résultats mons est pour le
retour de rio sans que ça n'a pas été
possible d'en intégrer dans le
calendrier parlementaire de la dic le
gouvernement de mettre à l'ordre du jour
de la session extraordinaire je vois
simplement pour les autres débats qui ne
vous seul pagano vous solliciteront pour
les deux conférences à venir en 2012
attirer votre attention au fait qu'il
soit important qu'on ait un lieu et le
parlement le sénat soit ce lieu des
changes sur les conférences
internationales de façon à en faire
connaître la teneur et sensibiliser les
citoyens sur leurs enjeux jeu roberto
piano oui madame la ministre
c'était une question sur les gaz de
schiste que je souhaite est posée mais
vous avez répondu par avance et je n'en
attendais pas moins de vous puisque je
connais votre position sur ce sujet vous
l'avez rappelé dans votre intervention
vous avez déposé une proposition de loi
pour demander la rive ferme et définitif
de l'exploration et l'exploitation des
gaz de schiste ce qui nous convient
parfaitement et qui convient également à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens qui sont
inquiets quant à l'avenir pour leur
environnement et surtout pour la
ressource en eau potable car cela
risquerait de poser d'énormes problèmes
merci monsieur roland courteau
oui le ministre laurence rossignol a
évoqué ce sujet je voudrais simplement
indiqué que sur le chemin de la
transition énergétique sobre en carbone
la france a pris des engagements
je n'y reviens pas vous avez cité et
pourtant la législation sur l'éolien
terrestre a été verrouillé le
photovoltaïque a été frappé par son
caractère excessivement restrictif et
j'ajouterais que les avantages fiscaux
pour les énergies renouvelables et le
dernier et les économies d'énergie sont
passés de 3 milliards en 2009 à environ
4 milliards en 2012 au rythme actuel
nous n'atteindrons pas les objectifs
fixés à l'horizon 2020 quelles sont vos
intentions sur ce point deuxième point
monsieur le président
concernant l'éolien en mer le premier
appel d'offres au début de l'année n'a
permis de sélectionner des projets qu'à
hauteur de 10 de 2 gigawatts et non
trois comme prévu initialement
question le gouvernement compte-t-il en
conséquence lancer rapidement le second
appel d'offres cela permettrait de
rattraper quelque peu le retard pris
mais aussi de soutenir la mise en place
des usines et de la filière industrielle
en france
troisième point et dernier point
concernant l'hydroélectricité de
nombreux petits producteurs qui arrive
cette année au terme d'un contrat
d'achat conclu en 1997 pourrait
bénéficier d'un renouvellement de leur
contrat au terme de la loi nome 6 en âge
je cite un programme de travaux un
projet d'arrêté doit fixer le montant
d'investissement qui permettra le
renouvellement de ses contrats
pouvez vous nous indiquer quand vous
pensez pouvoir prendre cet arrêté
madame la ministre vous avez abordé la
question de la transition énergétique et
on sait que le gouvernement va ramener
le nucléaire à hauteur de 50 % il ya eu
un grand débat national sur ces
questions il été tranchée l'idée
maintenant c'est de savoir dans les
foyers est ce que on va augmenter
considérablement le déficit du commerce
extérieur en achetant des panneaux
solaires qu'ils sont favoris qui ne sont
pas fabriqués chez nous en achetant des
chaudières de nouvelle génération à
condensation qui ne sont pas fabriqués
chez nous et il y à un risque énorme
s'il n'ya pas avec la décision du
changement de mix énergétique et d'avoir
une volonté extrêmement forte de
commencer à fabriquer et de je pense
la question est posée on sent que les
industries traditionnelles marque le pas
et perdre des emplois et les gisements
d'emplois nouveaux sont certainement
dans ces nouvelles technologies et là et
notamment dans le mix énergétique
nouveau alors la question je poserai
madame la ministre
quels contacts avez vous avec le
ministre du redressement industriel avec
les régions pour justement faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des politiques
extrêmement vigoureuse pour que nous ça
ne se traduise pas par un nouveau
déficit du commerce extérieur mais qu'au
contraire on arrive à réindustrialiser
le pays en partie avec ce nouveau mix
énergétique
la seconde chose je savais en ce moment
il ya le problème de psa je regardais
les les comment le le plan social de psa
qui touche essentiellement des cadres
techniciens au moins pour deux tiers et
je me dis que dans beaucoup de petites
et moyennes entreprises
il pourrait être tout à fait important
d'avoir ces ressources humaines pour
justement essayer d'avoir des
productions nationales dans des domaines
où nous sommes et l'allemagne j'ai fini
là dessus a créé trois cent soixante dix
mille emplois
dans les énergies nouvelles et nous nous
sommes à la traîne
voilà mais on peut être en face
complètement in martiale mais
j'attendais la question monsieur
fauconnier maintenant la ministre juste
rapidement une question sur le stockage
de l'eau en particulier des réserves de
la colline air entre la déréglementation
du précédent gouvernement juste avant
les élections et la réglementation
tatillonne que l'on connaissait les
porteurs de projets aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il ya un chemin
il ya surtout une urgence donc quelles
sont vos intentions sur ce sujet merci
fauconnier madame bourget a suivi la wii
les réseaux de chaleur
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vais prolonger la question
de roland courteau concernant les
sources d'énergie renouvelables et en
particulier pour puisque vous le savez
certainement le précédent gouvernement
avait lancé une procédure de mise en
concurrence des concessionnaires des
grands barrages
je suis sénatrice de la corrèze en
bordure de la dordogne et j'aimerais
savoir où en est la situation justement
de cette mise en concurrence qui
intéressent évidemment les collectivités
territoriales et de nombreux opérateurs
aussi bien nationaux qu'internationaux
c'était ma première question la deuxième
concerne le plan ecophyto de mu 2018 et
en particulier j'aimerais savoir si au
delà de ce que la mission du sénat mène
que la mission du sénat mène sur les
pesticides vous pensé prendre des
initiatives pour ce qui concerne
l'environnement et en particulier le
traitement par les collectivités
territoriales des deux ce qui les
concerne du domaine public
concernant donc l'utilisation des
produits pesticides
je vous remercie
je vous en prie mes chers collègues pour
que madame la ministre je vous réponde
et doit partir je vous rappelle à 30
19h30 et donc il nous reste monsieur
denis c'est monsieur vial ah ben non je
suis navré parce que là ça va pas être
possible
monsieur denis ce bon monsieur vial
alors deux points très rapidement
puisque le premier concerne les marchés
capacitaire l'a dit sainte agnès de ce
qui vous a interrogé tout à l'heure sur
les décrets notre collègue dantec vous a
évoqué la la notion européenne et j'ai
vu que vous avez rebondit immédiatement
sur ce point le ministre
les décrets qui sont aujourd'hui
attendus sont des décret est important
car nous avons un gisement en france de
la capacité de mobiliser pour facilement
6 à 8 gigawatts
aujourd'hui il ya des industriels qui
sont dans la tente et tout tient au
décret donc je me permets d'attirer
votre attention sur ce point deuxième le
deuxième question sur le bois énergie
vous avez également évoqué votre intérêt
pour cette filière il y a aujourd'hui
ministre une difficulté sérieuse c'est
que dans les plans croquis sont engagés
nous avons une distorsion entre l'offre
mis sur le marché et les capacités à tel
point que dans ma région j'ai des
industries papetières qui ont dû arrêter
leur fabrication pendant plusieurs jours
par manque d'approvisionnement de
plaquettes papier on sait que là on est
dans une filière éminemment
développement durable puisque la
plaquette papier et réutilisées 7 6 à 7
fois
or je pense que les préfets de région
devrait effectivement suivre les plans
régionaux avec beaucoup plus de 2 de
précisions je crois que c'est la
dernière question monsieur d'aunis merci
monsieur le président madame un ministre
mais c'est le président sur collègues
contenterait beaucoup de choses ont été
dites à deux éléments et j'éviterais de
vous refaire une question écrite sur la
dame
étant donné que laurence rossignol vient
d'aborder ce laps de questions la
première
vous connaissez les difficultés qu'il y
as pour la filière ovine traditionnelle
dans les alpes avec la cohabitation avec
le loup il y a des demandes aujourd'hui
de la part des professionnels de la
filière d'une rencontre êtes vous
disposé à ouvrir le dialogue à reprendre
le dialogue avec les éleveurs deuxième
question par rapport à l'eau des
éléments ont souvent des situations
sienne avec des concessions d'état qui
ont été transférés 1800 enfin d980 des
le sénateur je suis désolé mais la
ministre doit nous quitte et je suis
désolé on hante la première question sur
le loup est arrivée et sur le reste et
j'aurai le bonheur de la voir dimanche
puisque sa première visite officielle
sera le maritime et ça se sent direct
merci bien excuser moi sinon je propose
de devenir une
une fois supplémentaire avant la clôture
de la session sans aucune difficulté
en ce qui concerne le schéma national
des infrastructures de transport le
nouveau gouvernement entend conduire une
politique responsable en matière de
transport centré sur des investissements
réaliste permettant de répondre à court
et moyen terme aux besoins des usagers
donc il y a en effet une volonté de
rupture par rapport à l'accumulation de
promesses irréalistes qui ont été faites
par le précédent gouvernement une
politique ambitieuse qui sera la nôtre
en matière d'infrastructures de
transport ne peut avoir de sens que si
elle est crédible et quand je disais
qu'il y avait une accumulation de
promesses irréalistes
je rappelle les chiffres puisque il y
avait 2 145 milliards
de dépenses sur 20 à 30 ans 105
milliards pour les investissements de
régénération modernisation 140 pour les
investissements de développement donc le
premier ministre a rappelé que l'état
veillera à la préservation à la
modernisation de nos infrastructures de
transport au service d'une mobilité plus
sobre et plus équitable ce qui conduira
à la mise en place d'une commission des
sages pour évaluer les projets
d'infrastructures nouvelles en fonction
de ses priorités
la vision du snit telle taxe est
aujourd'hui essentiellement sur les
nouvelles infrastructures doit de mon
point de vue évoluer vers une vision
axée sur l'aménagement du territoire la
réponse immédiate en termes de qualité
de service à des besoins de déplacements
de nos concitoyens donc l'amélioration
des transports quotidiens la lutte
contre la fracture territoriale et la
desserte des territoires enclavés
voilà les priorités ce qui me permet de
préciser que je travaille en totale
confiance avec le ministre lebel et
transpole qui est en charge et en
responsabilité à mes côtés sur ces
dossiers en revanche le véhicule
électrique
c'est en effet la direction générale de
l'énergie et du climat qui suit la
politique dans ce domaine et j'ai
d'ailleurs fait des propositions aux
ministres du redressement productif pour
qu'il y ait un système de pilotage de la
stratégie française en la matière qu'ils
soient plus réactifs plus simple et donc
plus efficace
les transports par ailleurs bien entendu
là la consommation d'énergie liée au
transport et donc au mode de vie qui en
résultent sera bien sûr partie
intégrante du débat national sur la
transition énergétique en ce qui
concerne le photovoltaïque j'annoncerai
dans les prochains jours
la validation certainement de la
procédure d'appel d'offres pour les
installations de grande puissance
supérieure à 250 kilowatts pour les
installations de moyenne puissance dont
les résultats de l'appel d'offres ne
sont pas satisfaisants avec des prix
assez cher je suis en train d'étudier le
bon dimensionnement mais en tout cas il
y aura je pense dès la semaine prochaine
un signe clair qui sera adressé dans ce
domaine par rapport à des projets qui
sont aussi attendus sur les territoires
en ce qui concerne la commission des
risques miniers bien entendu elle sera
consultée il y avait une question aussi
sur de madame didier sur le coût des
déchets donc je voulais vous dire parce
que vous êtes la présidente du groupe
d'études sur ce sujet que moi je pense
qu'un état des lieux global j'en
discutais d'ailleurs tout à l'heure avec
la mf également nécessaire et donc je
suis tout à fait ouverte à des échanges
à ce sujet et à ce que vous vous
saisissiez par un certain nombre de
travaux de cette question sur les
vingt-deux monsieur dantec
j'attends avec intérêt le rapport sur le
coût de l'électricité
en ce qui concerne les objectifs
européens en matière de réchauffement
climatique l'europe garde toujours cette
volonté de tenir ces objectif est d'être
exemplaire j'ai échangé avec la
commissaire chargée du des négociations
sur le climat à berlin hier à la fois à
propos de la volonté européenne que sa
directive sur le ts aviation soit
respecté sa portée juridique avait
d'ailleurs été validé et nous avons eu
un échange aussi sur le marché du
carbone et la façon dont la commission
européenne pourrait agir pour soutenir
le prix du carbone il y a plusieurs
leviers
un de ceux là et le fait que les
objectifs de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre soient relevées ce
qui suppose que cela puisse se faire de
façon crédible et est donc cela entraîne
l'adhésion des 27 mais il ya sinon
d'autres
d'autres évolutions possibles j'ai
répondu à la question de monsieur point
trop sur les lgv travers de ce que j'ai
dit sur le snit par rapport à ce que
disait laurence rossignol sur les
mesures concernant les énergies
renouvelables donc j'ai indiquées sur le
sur le photovoltaïque il peut y en avoir
d'autres que je vois que que je perçois
comme des mesures transitoires ayant
vocation à donner un signal de
persévérance à ces filières et à ces
secteurs dans la tente de règles stables
qui résulteront du débat sur la
transition énergétique parce que nous
devons mettre en place un cadre
réglementaire et
des sujets de financement qui soit
stable et qui donne une visibilité dans
l'ensemble des énergies renouvelables en
ce qui concerne les décrets c'est vrai
que le décret sur l'ademe qui avait été
pris d'ailleurs je crois en pleine
campagne électorale a posé des
difficultés
moi je crois beaucoup aux stratégies des
concentrés ou décentralisée notamment
pour l'ailé politique de sobriété
énergétique pour les politiques de
développement des énergies renouvelables
je pense que les collectivités
territoriales font des choses
exemplaires et donc certainement jeu je
regarderai de nouveau ce décret après
mon est entretenu avec
avec l'ademe l'autre décret que nous
aurons l'occasion de réexaminer
certainement lors de la conférence
environnementale pour avoir une
concertation à ce sujet c'est le décret
sur la responsabilité sociale des
entreprises et enfin je suis absolument
favorable à ce que moi même le ministre
des affaires étrangères est aussi le
ministre en charge du développement puis
si on venir devant le sénat avant les
différentes conférences internationales
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
voilà donc pour cette audition qui a eu
lieu mardi après midi au sénat
delphine batho donc ministre de
l'écologie et de l'énergie a été entendu
par les sénateurs de la commission du
développement durable et ceux de la
commission des affaires économiques
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire le 22 heures présentée par
pierre henri gergonne vous pouvez
toujours bien se retrouver la séance sur
notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne fin de journée sur la chaîne
parlementaire
je